live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
where Dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I'm Dave Ramsey your host this is
your favorite theme our America the
millionaire theme our we're going to do
a millionaire theme our this hour which
means we're going to talk to
millionaires and ask them how they did
it because there's a whole bunch of lies
out there being spread in the political
sector and people with agendas to be
socialists and communists talking about
how that America is ruined and you
cannot become a millionaire anymore in
America and wealth inequality and the
little man can't get ahead so you need
to elect me president because I'll fix
your life which is all a bunch of crap
Trump is not going to fix your life and
Hillary is not going to fix your life
neither one of them are they're not and
the people that thought Obama was going
to fix their life they're vastly
disappointed right now because he didn't
fix their life turns out as a lie you
have to fix your life and in that effect
you know in this political crap that is
spread around is that somehow you've
done something wrong if you become
wealthy you must have been a crook the
only way you can become wealthy as you
must inherit the money
you know the only way you become healthy
you know people that are the worst
givers in the world are all rich people
which is actually the opposite of the
truth you know yeah you got to be a rock
star or an NFL or NBA player to be a
millionaire not true and so we we debunk
those lies that are out there in the
culture by bringing on actual real
millionaires occasionally and ask them
about themselves and how they got to be
worth a million dollars now also stupid
politicians say stuff like you know if
you make a million dollars a year
well that's making a million dollars
ears not a millionaire doofus a
millionaire is when you have a million
dollar net worth or greater and your net
worth is an accounting function
defined as what you own minus what you
owe your assets minus your liabilities
when that equals a million dollars
you're a millionaire if you own a house
that's worth nine hundred thousand and
you have three hundred thousand in your
401k and you don't have any debt then
you have a 1.2 million dollar net worth
that's how it works you add up what you
own subtract what you owe and if that it
could equal to million dollars you're a
millionaire some people are millionaires
anything feel like they're millionaires
because it's really you know a lot of
them don't have most of them don't have
opulent lifestyles now if you get up
over ten million dollar net worth
sometimes you start to see some of their
wealth but most of them are very
nonplussed so we're going to take calls
from millionaires this hour and teach
you with their lives how you can become
a millionaire it's that simple
Glenn's going to start us off in
Oklahoma City hey Glen how are you oh
man better than I deserve Dave good so
what's your net worth sir my wife and I
were five point five million dollars
very cool and what is that primarily
invested in one of the big chunks yeah
75% of course is in stocks and mutual
funds part of it and the IRA and part of
it just in another money that we can get
you about penalty 20% in real estate and
about right now about 5% in cash okay
and so what's like your home worth as an
example about half a million dollars
okay cool and what's been your income
throughout your working lifetime average
a range or something
yeah it's probably you know about a
hundred and forty thousand a year for
the last 30 years okay cool and how much
of this 5.5 million did you inherit my
money that I inherited was when my
father passed about nine years ago he
had a life insurance policy and proceeds
from that were about two hundred fifty
thousand dollars to me okay but you were
already a millionaire by then weren't
you yeah yeah so it was just you know
just a little bit extra gave us you know
got you and how old are you now you and
your wife I'm 56 and my wife is 52 okay
very cool
and what has been your career in your
work
lifetime so I was a Drilling Engineer
for an oil company and started out as a
roughneck you know working on the rig
and then went back to university and and
then we lived all over the world and
came back to to Oklahoma here about a
year ago to be close to our children my
wife is a pharmacist but she worked very
little because she stayed home took care
of the children mostly and then she went
overseas she wasn't able to work that
much got you well and what was your
degree in that engineering or chemical
engineering or petroleum engineering
truck petroleum engineering okay all
right cool and what was your GPA 3.4 I
believe overall okay and how much of
this wealth is was caused by you
borrowing money to invest
we never borrowed any money to invest
like in the stock market I think one
time one time we bought a rent house
when we were in Canada we bought a rent
house so and we borrowed money to do
that actually Dave you know I years ago
I did stupid thing you know I I I bought
my house with the cheap and got a
mortgage so that I could quote get the
better return in the market and you know
that didn't work out so well so I so I
was a so debt has paid very little very
little part in it don't you okay what
about giving what has been your giving
patterns so of course we're Christian so
we've tithe you know when I was making
four bucks an hour
I was tithing and you know now we're
still tithers we've supported the same
missionaries for thirty years and you
know give to our family of course to
meet their needs and then we funded a
scholarship in my father's name that's a
perpetual so that it's even if we never
give any more to it you know I don't you
go on again so what's the most expensive
pair of jeans you ever bought hundred
dollars okay cool and how many brand new
cars did you buy prior to having at
least a million dollar net worth
before having a millionaire prior
probably I bought eight new cars total
in my life prior to being a millionaire
probably four or five of those okay so
you bought car new cars okay cool all
right
and how many non-fiction books do you
read here well I tried to read a couple
of months you know so I say 24 I got a
list of books you know that I have read
and I need to need to read still but
yeah so a couple of months
not counting Dave Ramsey books what's
the best book you've read in the last 12
months oh man
the founding fathers on leadership it's
about George Washington and those guys
and you know yeah and then of course
failing failing forward or intentional
living by by Maxwell yeah I love Maxwell
he's going to be at our entree summit in
the in the spring so I'm very cool well
Glenn you and your wife are great
American heroes you have leave lived the
dream do you think that if somebody
starting out today was working a
roughneck they could work their way up
like you have oh yeah I mean it's uh you
know it's the pay yourself first right
you know ties and then put money aside
and then live on the rest live below
your means and delay gratification and
yeah yeah so it can still be done that
well it's an honor to talk to you sir
thank you for calling in and
participating in our Millionaire theme
our five point five million dollar net
worth and they made over 100 or average
140 thousand dollar income this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income